die Qual der Wahl auf den Speisekarten
vieler asien-restaurants stehen oft
hunderte Gerichte und in der Küche nur
ein Koch trotzdem sind die
Vorbereitungen in 5 Minuten erledigt
einfacher Job umfüllen zusammenrühren
anrichten Geld verdienen Sebastian
entlarvt den baukastentrick und
kombiniert fertige Tiefkühlware in
0,nicht zu vermeintlich verschiedenen
Menüs
[Musik]
was habe ich dir bringen
okay ja ich nehme Klassiker
Schweinefleisch mit süß-sauer jawohl und
Reis jawohl wird gemacht die
Bestellungen will Sebastian lege ganz
alleine kochen
dafür hat er im Großhandel eingekauft
Fleisch Fisch Gemüse und Soßen fix und
fertig vorbereitet von der
Lebensmittelindustrie
proteinbasis Schweinefleisch Rindfleisch
Meeresfrüchte Garnelen Tofu
[Musik]
Böse gibt es vorbereitet im
Tiefkühlbeutel paprika und Pilze sind
bereits gewaschen und maschinell
geschnitten das spart Arbeitszeit und
Personal
so arbeiten viele Asia Restaurants der
fertige China Mix kommt tatsächlich
direkt aus China
und
die Soße gibt mir garantiert heute nicht
aus ne
alles schön Kanister Ware
hannesübliches Zeugs habe ich nicht
selber abgefüllt die Industrie verkauft
den Restaurants Soßen im XXL-Format alle
sind komplett Verzehr fertig
darunter ist auch die beliebteste aller
Soßen sweet Chili Sebastian Lee gebaut
die einmal nach
süße Chilisoße ein absoluter Allrounder
der asiatischen Küche ob zum Kochen zum
Dippen überall wird sie verwendet
sie denken bestimmt oh Geheimrezeptur
wie bei Ketchup nee das sind nur ein
paar Zutaten aber die Hauptzutat Wasser
und das nicht wenig
er als 50% aus Wasser
[Musik]
aber die zweite Zutat auf der
Zutatenliste ist Zucker
Zucker und noch mehr Zucker
Wasser und Zucker sind die Hauptzutaten
der Soße für das Aroma sorgen Chili und
Knoblauch dazu kommen noch Salz Säure
Regulator und Bindemittel
aromatisierte wassersauce mit Chili
Geschmack
so müsste es eigentlich drauf stehen
einmal aufkochen und pürieren Salz und
Säure Regulator machen die Soße haltbar
reicht
schönes locker zwei drei Liter Soße
1 € eingesetzt 20 € verdient
[Gelächter]
nach dem Abkühlen hat die süße
Chilisauce ihre typische dickflüssige
Konsistenz dank Bindemittel Zucker und
Wasser aber wenig Chili diese 4,5 Liter
Soße Kosten im Großhandel 21,30 € macht
pro Essen gerade einmal 40 Cent
auch die anderen Soßen sind super billig
55 Cent pro Portion kosten Sie im
Schnitt
Fertigsoßen liefern Sebastian lege in
seinem Restaurant den Geschmack
aus fix und fertigen Zutaten kann er mit
dem baukastentrick viele vermeintlich
verschiedener Gerichte zubereiten
ja das sind die Vorbereitungen gemacht
restaurantöffnung ist um 18 Uhr und ich
komme um 17 Uhr und stellen um meine
Sachen zusammen und kann 100 Gerichte
kochen einfacher Job umfüllen
zusammenrühren anrichten Geld verdienen
für die Zubereitung reicht ein Wort
zack ein bisschen Öl das reicht auch
schon
bisschen hiervon
[Musik]
bisschen davon
lege startet mit Gewürzpaste und
Tiefkühlgemüse egal für welches
bestellte Gericht
erste Bestellung Schweinefleisch süß
sauer zack Schweinefleisch nicht zu viel
kurz einmal anbraten
so Attacke hier bisschen Soße
sweet Chili kommt zum Einsatz noch ein
bisschen
fertige Zutaten im Wok anbraten dafür
ist kein ausgebildeter Koch nötig als
Beilage gibt es Reis oder Nudeln alles
vorbereitet
[Musik]
zwei Minuten gemacht ja
mehr als 100 Gerichte auf der Karte und
trotzdem steht nur eine Person in der
Küche
Asia Restaurants Arbeiten traditionell
mit wenig Personal das macht sie
unschlagbar günstig
Garnelen rein
Gemüse rein hier ein bisschen was
Hübsches
nicht zu viel ne wir wollen ja Geld
verdienen
Personal ist teuer in Deutschland
da lohnt es sich die Pilze in China
schneiden zu lassen und haben wir schon
wieder zwei Portion fertig so schnell
geht das hier stehen mehr als 30
Gerichte auf der Karte ist das ein
Zeichen für die baukastenmethode das
heißt auch in diesen Restaurants kommt
wahrscheinlich tiefgekühltes auf die
Teller jetzt habe ich eine vegetarische
Bestellung da machen wir Pilze Teriyaki
vegetarisch auch das ist natürlich gar
kein Problem ich habe meine Soßen ich
habe meine Proteine ich könnte jetzt
auch ein bisschen Tofu Arbeiten total
egal
wenig Zutaten viele
Kombinationsmöglichkeiten
der Trick funktioniert durch geschickte
Kombination der Bestandteile ein
Beispiel als Basis dienen 5
Proteinquellen und Gemüse
mit nur vier verschiedenen Soßen kann
man damit schon 20 Gerichte kochen nur
vier Beilagen multiplizieren das ganze
auf 80 verschiedene Angebote
[Musik]
ja das ist hier der Trick und wir denken
was für eine raffinierte Küche
von der Bestellung bis zum Servieren
Vergehen im Asia Restaurant meistens nur
wenige Minuten so auch im lachenden lege
ja
willkommen sei ruhig ehrlich ich ertrage
Kritik also ich muss ehrlich sagen ich
finde es lecker okay also ich fand auch
dass das Gemüse war ziemlich frisch auch
bissfest aber viel Sojasoße sehr viel so
das Gemüse fertige Soße und
vorbereitetes Fleisch schon schmeckt es
bei lege wie im Asia Restaurant da steht
ein achtarmiger Oktopus Koch der kocht
300 Essen die Stunde weil halt alles
vorbereitet ist und er nur die
jeweiligen Kombination miteinander
variieren muss und zack hat er so zig
verschiedene Gerichte auf einmal gekocht
Wahnsinn echt nicht gedacht
Asia Restaurants in ganz Deutschland
arbeiten immer öfter mit industriell
hergestellten Zutaten
in guten asiatischen Restaurant stehen
wenige Gerichte auf der Karte die dann
auch mehr als 10 € Kosten
günstige Restaurants setzen dagegen
meist auf Soßen im xxl-kanister und
vorgekochte Nudeln aus Fernost
[Musik]